Larry Bird Larry Joe bird is on the line
coach how you doing good Reggie how you
doing today I'm doing fantastic now I
you probably didn't get a chance to see
this but we were playing that game four
shot versus Chicago that Derrick McKey
through to me and I lightly nudged
Michael Jordon and got the shot off and
I was doing
pirouette they if people they don't talk
about the shot that come up to me they
talk about your reaction to the shot
which there was no reaction like you
were stoic your expression did not
change well Reggie there's so much going
on at that time right it was a
hard-fought game we were up that we were
down you came off the screen from the
left side to the right side you got the
ball
Michael pushed off on you you make the
shot and I didn't know if a whistle blew
or not I didn't know what happened then
I looked up and his four tenths of a
second now you know in the NBA right
that they're going to put four tenths of
a second up there which scared the hell
outta me it should have been two point
two seconds no one that there's going to
Michael he's going to get the ball and
he's going to get a clean look he got he
got the ball he pump-faked took one
dribble and almost made he banked it in
and it came out and really it took three
seconds get the shot off but you knew
they're going to have an opportunity to
score so I was in amazement because they
should never been four tenths of a
second it should have been two kids game
should have been over but they gave him
an opportunity to win the game and
that's what scared me and by the way
that was in our building that wasn't in
Chicago so your honor we would have had
a better score keeper in our own
building a little Homer well you know I
walked down there
with the four tents and made sure that
it's going to start the clock on time
but if you remember Michael got up
pump-faked it took one dribble and still
got off in time and you know being a
home at before the volume came in they
should I had the horn go off into in
today's game less than a minute let's
say less than thirty second in today's
game who are some of the players because
you watch them all obvious being the
president of the Indiana Pacers who are
those go-to guys those go to players
like you were for those great Boston
Celtics team and you can put Paul George
in this category
yeah Paul Paul is getting better and
better but you know LeBron you know he's
gonna get it and try drive get to the
hole get fouled Kevin Durant's really
good Westbrook's gonna try attack the
rim and in situations you always like
guys go into the hole you know a lot of
times guys settle for off-balance shots
fadeaways you know there's a fight
against the clock by like the guys that
get it and try to make something happen
to the rim and and and you know leave
the the call-up to the officials and
LeBron Zhou is very good at it there's
so many great players in our on our
league now Reggie that can make shots at
in the games it's it's it's really fun
to watch the style of the NBA today more
threes
you know the floor stretched a little
bit more there's not as much contact the
physical play is gone how do you think
your game would have translated in
today's game well you always have to
make adjustments with your game it's
just like coming from college to the
pros you know I had to get a step-back
shot at shoot a ball a little bit higher
at times in the post you know I never
worked on the three-point shot when I
played I know around when they had the
all-star game I I shot a few threes but
I never went out there and just shot you
know like a hundred of 200 threes
everyday like guys do now I mean when
our players walk on the court now they
do a little bit then they go right to
the three-point line so the game has
changed in that and I'm sure back in the
day if we shoot a lot more threes we
would have spent a lot more time working
on it we're talking with Larry Bird on
the Dan Patrick show what conversations
before Paul George left for Rio did you
have
in light of everything that happened two
years ago obviously the horrific leg
injuries did you guys if any have any
conversations before he left and by the
way as you know he dropped 20 points
last night versus whele yeah the kid
just keeps getting better and better
he's a hard worker he's dedicated to his
craft
Hyup we'd talked a little bit but
nothing about the injury we put that
away we don't even like to talk about
now I knew when he went over there was
going to be brought up time after time
but I think Paul sort of put him back of
his mind and just looking forward to
playing and get trying to get better he
enjoys the experience I know I've been
texting off and on a little bit he's
having fun and he can't wait to get back
and see what kind of team we have this
year you were a part of the greatest
team ever assembled the 1992 dream team
obviously you weren't 100% you weren't
at your best we all know what you guys
did on the court that was evident we all
watched those games but everything I
heard coming out of that can you walk us
through
I heard the practices were the best
basketball no one's ever seen am I
correct on that well before we got over
there you know once we got into the
Olympics we didn't really practice why I
only think we practice at all but we
were in sent a free tour was at San
Diego none of San Diego we was somewhere
and we were practicing we had a lot of
fun when the college kids came in we
practice against them that was a lot of
fun and there's you know there's always
a lot of good competition when you have
magic on one team and Michael on the
other team and you know we had Patrick
and a lot of guys that talked a lot of
smack but it was fun remember they said
one of the greatest games that no one
ever seen that was one of the worst
practices I ever seen in my life
all the guys were doing was talking I
think the game was like 28 to 25 or
something like that but other now we had
a good time is a great experience and
and you know winning the goal for your
country is always the ultimate and
that's why I told Paul and he was
excited about going and I said the one
thing is
never have this experience again so
while you're there you might as well
take advantage of it now are you one of
those guys that were kind of gone a
little bit you know well not really I
mean because you know my time was over I
knew I wouldn't go and play a whole lot
I think I just average 18 minutes over
there we had a stacked team we knew some
nights we're going to play you know
fifteen or twenty minutes and some
nights maybe not as much because it's
just so much talent on that team and you
know everybody wanted to play here but I
want to get through minutes in but we
knew going out we're going to win by a
large margin and we just want to make it
a great experience for all was there one
guy on that team that you really didn't
know but you kind of got to know a
little bit better throughout that time
yeah you do you spend some time with
some guys I didn't know David Robinson's
as well and crawl obviously Kristen
Laettner some of the guys that played on
the West Coast you didn't know as well
but as far as magic and Michael and
Charles and him guys you know I knew
them pretty well you know shifting
towards the paster you guys made a
change obviously gone is Frank Vogel who
was there for six year you came out and
said you want your Pacers to be more
up-tempo run a little bit more
you hired Nate McMillan can you kind of
walk us through what the game plan is
going to be for Nate's vision for this
team you've added Jeff Teague Thaddeus
Young so what's the overall game plan
here for the Indiana Pacers going
forward for the upcoming season well
when we think we want to run a little
bit more Reggie we never was talking
like Golden State we don't have that
type of player or Oklahoma City we you
know we're basically going to try to
score more points off the defensive end
by getting skills and and maybe running
a little bit more especially with Jeff
Teague able to penetrate and Monta Ellis
being able to get in the pain kicking
out we want to style where we can you
know score but I like to score 105
points a game maybe 106 if we can and
still defend the way were capable of
defending you know we still have Dan
Burke here he's always been our
defensive guy like dick Carter was back
in the day I was here they're very good
you know we expected to fin well but you
know we want to get out and get open a
little bit
and maybe shoot more threes I know
Nate's got a game plan and and you know
back when next got over 900 games he's
coached in the NBA and and he's going to
style and he knows the game has changed
a little bit we got to get out and move
a little bit more and I think he's gonna
do an excellent job for us well speaking
of shooting threes coach we have a we
had a poll question on here just to let
you know I had nothing to do with this
poll question I'm gonna let one of the
Dan Nets
McLovin ask you this question cuz he's
been dying to ask you this okay if you
had a better way okay who would win a
three-point shooting contest Larry Bird
or Reggie Miller now no and in their
prime in the by the way you want just to
let you know you you have this here's
how I'll put it Reggie
my teammates in the pros I would win
hands down if I had the opportunity the
great opportunity to coach it I'd say
you win oh okay look I'm just letting
you know I picked you it was a it was a
dead tie too - I was the tiebreaker no
question you at the three-point
competition walking in the locker room
who's playing did you really say that
who's playing for a second yeah I did
because I you know I didn't realize it's
so much tension only you know I'm out
there every day and from these fans and
who were some who were some of the guys
in the competition at that time when you
walked in who wasn't in that field I
come on coach you know no I don't really
remember del L del Ellis yeah Dale was
yeah that's rip yeah Hodges Johnson yeah
the kid that's refereeing now right Oh
Lester really um would Leon would Leon
would Leon would never cross three-point
line all he did was ever ever his boys
shot three so I thought he might be the
competition because I've seen him shoot
before games you know he's knock him
down some when I walked in there he's
sitting there and I said boy him red
white blue blue balls are so slippery I
can't hold on to him
and the next time I can isokay now that
I've down the nitty-gritty who's coming
in second he already knows he's going to
win this I got lucky because almost got
beat in the first round but what was the
reaction after you said that like oh
that's just Larry legend or did it get
dead silence in there it was silent I
think they were a little nervous I like
I think they were nervous and then the
water they'll walk off with your hand up
of a come on coach come on well I I was
struggling that final round in Chicago I
know that and I just got hot there the
last two and a half racks you know when
you're shooting them you don't know what
the score is right but I had a feeling
by way the crowd was going I had to make
the last one and well I let it go I felt
it you know sometimes you shooting me
think you're going in they don't but
that one there look perfect all the way
so if it would have bounced out I would
have feel like an idiot well did it went
in I got lucky and got the check and
went home to tell you to tell you about
pressure when you were our head coach we
were 10 and 1 because we we knew we had
to win against one team all the time and
that was the Boston Celtics I don't care
what we wear else you didn't tell you
you didn't tell us but everyone around
you said you guys have to beat Boston
especially in Boston where we were five
and one so you talked about Roger that's
pressure is playing quite early
relationship that one the group one of
the greatest moments ever had in sports
was you know I never I always wanted to
win in Boston but I never want Boston to
lose because I know it's a great sports
town all that but the first time we went
into Boston was one of the greatest
experience after that game that I ever
felt it's like winning the championship
I can remember we had a backdoor play
the whole game but we knew was going to
work and you Mark waited to last bout
minute men have to in the game to run it
you went back door and got fouled and we
knew right there that ice the game what
color to play and no time coach thank
you for everything that you've done for
the game and for me having a chance to
play against you and then work
underneath you and to learn everything
about the game I truly appreciate I
wouldn't be at the level I am
yet this desk have a success I had if it
wasn't for you so I appreciate you
calling in and giving us an insight on
dream team one and in the Olympics and
the pasters so we really do appreciate
it
well thank you Reggie it's an honor and
I think you won the greatest and I know
you're one of the greatest and it's just
an honor to have you two to work for me
for a little bit but you had great
success you're still doing well and I'm
proud of you and I apologize about the
2000 Finals it's my fault that we didn't
get that championship seriously
so I appreciate it I'm sorry uh that's
Larry Bird everyone thank you guys so
appreciate a coach thank you good luck
ready mine thank you the legend the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience